ces films plastiques ont l'air anodin et
pourtant il s'agit de tubas perfusion
exportés dans plus de 140 pays
en tout ce sont près de 100 millions
d'éléments pharmaceutiques qui sont
produits cette année par l'entreprise
allemande b braun dans son usine de
nogent le rotrou
une production qui devrait augmenter de
60% à l'horizon 2023
et ce grâce à l'investissement de 60
millions d'euros sur ce site
aurélien un site très spécialisés c'est
le seul centre d'excellence mondial sur
les soins urinaire tous les dispositifs
médicaux que l'on fabrique pour le monde
entier
ce que ce soit les sons ou bien les
poches de recueil d'urines sont
uniquement fabriqués ici pour tout le
groupe b braun et la recherche et
développement et également ici 20
millions d'euros sont investis dans de
nouvelles machines et 45 millions dans
l'extension des bâtiments en parallèle
90 postes intérimaires seront
transformés en cdi sur les 550 emplois
de l'entreprise c'est une excellente
nouvelle pour la ville
parce que les brawn c'est le premier
employeur de la ville et du perche
ce fut une excellente nouvelle pour la
région parce que aujourd'hui les
industries de santé
ce soit des brawn novo nordisk servier à
gidy ce sont les plus gros investisseur
industriel de la région centre et ce
sont des dizaines et des dizaines de
millions d'euros qui sont en ce moment
même estime centre val de loire le plus
grand site en français nos gens et la
modernisation des machines avec aussi un
aspect maintenant à intégration de nos
strict apte à zéro c'est à dire la
dématérialisation aussi des claques et
flux donc pour nous c'est essentiel pour
rester compétitifs au niveau du monde
avec ses 60 millions d'euros injectés
sur cinq ans b braun est le deuxième
plus gros investisseur privé en région
centre val de loire derrière novo
nordisk spécialisée dans le traitement
du diabète
les entreprises de santé se porte donc
très bien